hey everyone i'm nate from hugging face
and today i'm going to show you how you
can share tensorboard training metrics
on the hug and face hub if you find this
video helpful give it a like and
consider subscribing to our youtube
channel for more content like this
to get tensorboard running remotely with
your hug and face model repo you just
need to upload the tf events files used
by tensorboard to a directory named logs
in your repo
let's see how this works with keras here
i'll quickly run through the denoising
autoencoder example from the kerastocks
that we covered it in the hug and face
hub keras integration video which i'll
include a link to
the difference here is that i'll
initialize a tensorboard callback to
track the training metrics and include
it when we call autoencoder.fit
once the model is finished training
we'll push it up to the hub
after that we can see the repo we
created but notice it does not have the
tensorboard training metrics yet that's
because we didn't upload them let's go
back and add them
when we pushed the model a directory
named after the model id we specified
was created
we'll just copy our logs directory from
the tensorboard callback into that
directory
now we'll use git add git commit and get
push to upload that new directory to our
repo
now that's finished let's take a look at
our model repo again and after loads
we'll see that a remote version of
tensorboard is in our repo when you
click the training metrics tab
these links are shareable which means
that you can send your results publicly
or privately to your teammates so you
always have access to both your training
metrics and the associated model
so that's how you add tensorboard
training metrics to the hug and face hub
if you found this video helpful give it
a like and consider subscribing to our
youtube channel
you can also join our discord server to
connect with over 3000 other people
interested in machine learning
thanks for watching until next time bye
[Music]
you